right look that way I appreciate today's
help me out here at night so topic
tonight it's going to be a discussion
around how to speak the language of
application we're going to touch upon
quite a few things here tonight so a
little bit of an intro we'll talk about
the software architect well that thing
seems to have different things morphing
with it we'll talk about continuous
design and application architecture
design principles we'll go over some
things it waited to generic models and
we'll talk more about modeling your
software a little bit about design
patterns and something called an
architecture architecture framework
centered around it so further ado let's
go ahead and jump into this so let's
mention my name's Brad Biermann I work
for a start-up downtown it's called
Kapow you get both with corporate events
management the advantages that stack
sequin the funny other fun stuff to know
to make it work technology night brick
is he a dragon technology I've been
there for two years
absolutely
what's that called professor string
website I have for about 10 years or so
it's dedicated to guitar strings and so
I also had wined them and have a company
up in Wisconsin that helps me do it and
so we've long strings for celebrities
and Carrie Underwood's guitarist
some strings for prints user - oh yeah
well the fun stuff that goes on with it
so professor string props check that out
so that's enough company that and so
little bit about the pal again we're in
the corporate event space we've been
thousands to murrs we've done five
thousand events different experiences
well we kind of bring to the table is
instead of going to just the hotel for a
large sales event or just doing the
regular steak house come on for some
different experiences as ice on the rise
so one of the things we've got is do you
have a corporate event that you want to
do it's a little different now for
something that was extra archery pizza
to us we even have adults a tricycle
we've partnered up with companies such
as Nike which you can go to a Nike store
and have a corporate event hosted it and
Nike absolutely loves it because you can
walk in to just a shoe store be wine
cheese food presentation everything is
set up and so what's that really great
we've really established quite a
platform before that but the big news
for us really came about it a month ago
and this was the head of it right here
so we actually just got bought cement
which is the largest company in this
space they're about 1.8 billion dollars
in size and they came in and bought us
and we were about 50 employees and so a
very exciting time about six years ago
or so many we're actually have to look
at for additional funding and see what
it says man you guys got a great thing
going
you got the number two office space and
Chicago that's actually a picture of our
office everything yeah we like to
capture what an event it looks like so
you better lose bargaining that
everything else so anyway let's get into
this stuff
okay so Software Architect well this is
an interesting role because it's it's
changed a little bit over the years
and it's it's often broad and what it
encompasses
have four buckets it really captures and
so we've got things that focus on
applications so really the designs and
structure of applications this is where
you'll see something to stop our
architect app architect or framework
check all right and so and then we've
got folks that are sales and support one
time I worked as vice president for
Oracle and I had close to 30 what they
call solution architects according to me
we would go out and feel the architects
and helped sell who I shouldn't say so
assist customers with the implementation
of the other right I think so as a
solution architect sometimes also knows
I feel architects so very popular in the
licensed software area and of course the
system's skilled an infrastructure
design this is the big one right now
cloud architect okay so we've made a lot
of changes from infrastructure
architected System Architect of course
operations let's go than the operations
a Enterprise Architect integration
architect so those are just common some
of the roles I know everybody's going to
seen those over the years and that but
they they take different shapes and
forms that we're going to focus on these
two and the discipline that's around so
what are the essential skills to really
become a Software Architect so to speak
it's so familiar with architectural
modeling language is a key piece so I'm
creating diagrams visual feature
representations got the old it do that I
never get with a framework like toga
Sackman
ITIL we'll get into those a little bit
we'll also talk a little bit about his
comfort amount of code base it might not
necessarily be a developer as an
architect but you could be around the
coalface it varies depending what you do
but you've definitely got some
experience is that walking into that so
your key thing here will be to present a
vision of how something is built in an
in a holistic way and also derive a
cost-effectiveness designs in options
mates for the symptoms this is kind of
interesting talk here because growing
and mentoring architects it's not really
happening at the level today
but that we see probably some years ago
particularly as things were more
waterfall work
their design period and that they were
going on there so that rauru became more
prominent today's an architect
well they don't see a lot of that
happening but hey how do you grow that
rope or something there because now
we're just doing our work of little
snippets low releases this thing called
agile came along so well it took a
little bit of a different turn there on
how it was growth and the other thing
too is you know it's kind of hard to
measure design as an investment is I got
a friend of mine that it sells
architectural rules he said you know
it's really not much different than
selling vitamins okay so it's something
we know we should do we know we should
put design and things there are no rush
to be agile we'll get right in another
cup and do this small one-week spread
there's two weeks back or something we
really haven't put down anything
diagrammatically we haven't put anything
visually you maybe just did some a
vision in code starts coming out week
after week after week after week year
after year after year
now you've got its massive codebase
perhaps pasta there's no design that can
that's rounded at all
everything so that's a sticky wicket and
why is it that way what some folks think
design slows develop okay I got to take
time after this I'm the [ __ ] to slow me
down or other marketeer in my favor the
codes are documentation it just says
just go really you know what it does
okay
there's there's what run so it really
doesn't describe things we'll get into
that
okay in agile development yeah the
engine envisioning step really not being
done correctly the way the least it was
intended the original manifesto the
design discipline guidelines principle
number eleven very loosely defined by
design that's the way we wanted we
didn't want to dictate how people should
design stuff but it also has kind of
manifested itself into that step for me
somewhat skipped or a bit just a little
bit of a discussion between you and I
it's how we're gonna do it okay let's go
and boom that that's how it starts so
code delivery in Geneva prioritized over
design and so what we never there's a
complete abandonment more architectural
skills that we really had a waterfall
and then so oftentimes I find a lot of
developers that I'm just basic you about
principles around that how to diagram
things will get again more into this
this is an interesting thing here so I
almost took this for my sign of braces
it's an industry sacrilege to say
anything bad about the agile manifesto
but it has some okay going from a
developer to an application architect so
as I've worked with developers you know
I have a group that reports to me and I
have folks that come in here and I'd
like to be an architect I've been in
development for a long time I'd like to
go more into that raw so well there's a
bit of a mind shift that goes on with
this so as a developer make sure your
work is more instant gratification I
write something they maybe runs and
renders and I get see the results right
there it's them it's it clear
application success it is measurable
okay your product is a compass as a
developer
the code is viewable you can actually
see recovered as a developer right it's
low in abstraction there it is in front
look different as an architect so the
nature the markets mark we did wave
gratification the success of
architecture is Hargett measure your
product as a vision the product is a
vision of waiting something that's being
put together is it is something that is
somewhat invisible to us but it's
omnipresent even in this room just from
construction we've got architecture here
how does it put together from our
architect perspective and that it's
something that's not really physical we
see the end product of the building but
what was down on the boot prevalence of
thinking that's a little bit of a vision
that God is here to what this
architecture the being so bit about
higher higher abstraction in this room
okay so where do you start
it's all right detective we'll start by
thinking about being design room okay
design girls where do you want to go
except to yeah we design driven
start there ease into it don't rush this
is a discipline this is a discipline of
being an architect think about how
something business consumer words and
the strategy behind this is the kind of
thinking loads of strategy take a lot
about how we're going to build something
resists the area's just
to draw something a rush into patterns
I've seen folks getting this is let me
just look feel like I got to draw
something I'm the architect I gotta get
up at the border
throw me a dry erase marker right now I
gotta do something
thank your time man it's a vision that's
the product and this takes a little
while to evolve that so again little bit
of discipline going from I'm writing
code right now boom Airlines type of
thing
look bit of a delay gratification that
goes on there so very strategic in
nature and it involves articulation it's
easy to overwhelm an audience and it's
the cartel okay no GMO criticism no
worry no more detail think big think big
let's start small little pieces kind of
look at the Amana fester those violent
agile suck get the big picture you get
the holistic view but let's start in
small pieces here and then start to
second the composition so coming first
of strategy our comb tells us what is
being done the code is really set of
instructions that's what it is okay
architecture tells us why something is
being done and how it is being done the
architecture is a vision of strategy
again so for folks I'd like to say hey
cog that's our documentation that's our
base well it really doesn't address why
are we doing this or how is this to be
done anything so against just the code
is and it said instructions for the
process yes so again thinking of those
higher levels here so one of the things
that we started focusing on here this
says I come up worried about something
called continuous design it'll go a
little bit into this those of you they
were around during the dot-com boom you
think about around like 1999 or so there
was something that came around that was
called extreme program okay
very popular at the time and this was
starting to come right after agile okay
so it had this thing in it called
continuous design and this is the
practice of creating and modifying the
design the system as its develop
rather than reporting a specific it to
specify the system completely before it
starts that's the whole genesis of we're
really agile
there was an interview with our Father
so where did you guys really start with
this when you worked in the ski lodge 17
million it says well we were having this
year's ayah about extreme program we
just need to really get this into some
type of quantification here
we're two years in the extreme
programming and as really were skunk
angel was the extreme programming part
in heaven this continuous design okay
continuous design was popularized by
extreme programming continuous design
also uses Testament moment which we use
a lot today the refactoring processes
okay so that's part of it where that
piece came from back in 99 when this guy
started a manifesto came around in 2001
yes so we've seen where this connect
today that's so that's kind of Genesis
before this comes from today we see
different companies taking on say oh
we're 100% agile some companies are
saying oh we're on the move from
waterfall in the agile okay so they're
right now it might be scrum for our
water scrub who knows whatever you call
it it's a mix of the two some folks have
come from waterfall they tried to go 100
percent and Rome may be good as far as
and Linda said you know what this
thing's got some gaps I I'd like to
hydrate this thing and that's what we're
starting to see is Angela's now but
we're kind of approaching 20 years on
this type of thing so it's it's been
with us for a while now so people are
really starting to embrace a lot of that
hybrid let me frame it so it's a mix
really of both we still love the things
that we saw in designs in waterfall we
still love the things that were analysis
in there but it doesn't work to spend
the next couple months working on that
we still want to keep this practice but
yet we still like our agility the
ability of coding
small releases quick deployments and
things like that so how do you get this
to work together with each other this is
how it kind of works okay so as you've
seen this this is actually our lifecycle
eight Capel
when I first came to capella is a
one-week sprint okay that's kind of
tough and as I came in seventy percent
of the points would roll over the
following week
sound for mayor yeah we've created a new
waterfall so it was a problem and as I
brought in younger engineers people have
less experience onboarding an absolute
nightmare because there was no
documentation around the code here's a
code base I've been going out for four
years
not one single document I had two
developers lead developers it's all up
here
oh oh okay just go talk to person X
person Y well person X a person why I'm
managing him I know this was about
relief so there goes stuff out the door
we've got to do something to get on top
of this right here and so continuous
design
let's bar that chapter out of extreme
programming I put it right here
stretching out to express so that allows
us to start thinking about this it's
called design just enough to get through
the spring in fact there's a popular
book out by Simon Brown we'll talk about
one of his models here a little bit it's
a book called just enough and that's
what it's kind of dressing just enough
to zone to get through the sprint but
now you've got a running document we've
now got a running already so what we do
in this is will create a crushed in four
plus one you might do a little bit of
you'll know Marlon you might do a c4
well a couple of things it continuously
lives with the code okay we could just
write the code and that do this but what
I found is this we start doing these
we're going to start to build in getting
some money on our morning man did that
become a lot easier because I just put
some diagrams rephrase see here's how
this process for iterative sequence
diagram here's a crutch tomorrow we'll
go into that a little bit that's what
that B's huge absolutely huge help as a
big success I think for a lot of junior
programmers what a challenge is we've
got today as an industry so you go out
to have look the job boards 90 percent
we're usually once and they it's a
senior developer what I'm gonna do have
a lot to join during work these code
best code bases have become so complex
and things and I'm not everybody has
documentation right you've now backed
yourself to that kind of corner I'm
going this is so complicated I've got
big ball
I really get into so we gotta find some
way to nurture these folks and so this
is kind of a cycle we spend just like
maybe a day or two putnis and we'll go
through we'll do our sprint planning to
do our grooming around those things do
the development and you know if you guys
have seen this if you've been in the
agile ok the typical rest of the cycle
events so that's how we're kind of
working in the two weeks making sure
that that continuous design piece is in
there that's really the focus of what
we're talking about as I started working
with the team I found a lot of folks
that are I'm gonna say from that we're
not around during the.com that we're not
around kind of it early days paydays of
waterfall things like you don't know
those disciplines really aren't taught
anymore and so we've kind of lost the
team us design principles so incremental
design design just enough again build
this brand but build upon the cave
applications holistic view that's what
you end up with is you keep going down
your sprints and building up your design
dock with it pretty soon over time
non-id have a built up codebase you've
also got the design built up with it too
and so one of the key successes for us
this is I push this forward in December
we were getting audited I didn't know it
was really an honor but it's called
diligence phase when we're out there
trying to get funding for free Kapow
they came in and wanted to see hey how
did you put this together and what they
were fully expecting was to see no
documentation it's a reject button as
what they've done with ninety-eight
percent of folks out looking for funding
when they came inertia guess what I had
them ready for all these design dives
have to him I just handed over right
there but we've passed right through
then they said we want to talk pretty
soon a couple weeks later we want to buy
and that's a huge difference because
that allowed an investor to come in and
see oh yeah I get it there's some
discipline around this thing
and I visually see what's going on with
it so build confidence in your funding
cycle build the change instead of going
to last that's that's key part of
obvious of being agile but not to say
we're going to go out there and spend
all this time on design but again just
an incremental piece and it's always
going to be changing so nobody has to
stay up on these diagrams either just
get the latest one we've created it's
always continuously going ok model to
analyze and reduce risk use design so
I've identified key engineering
decisions it's helps with cost obviously
maintenance whatever else recognizes the
way gratification that's really in the
design ok and use these models and
visualizations as a communication and
collaboration tool that's key for your
continuous design principles ok I first
started to have some engineering people
come up and say all right well I guess
we'll get the board and draw a picture
of what this kind of looks like for any
like wait a minute we're gonna talk
picture we're gonna do Chuck draw a
diagram just even the lexicon has been
lost a picture this is the picture it's
worth a thousand words this is a diagram
diagrams are right to the point
and often should be a few words boom
succinct focused on one thing right
there we don't want it to be interpret
there's got to be a specific segment and
get to a point of what it is that's
really kind one of the things we want to
look at here and so Simon Brown I've
said this guy's name a couple of times
this is really interesting
far too many teams a lot of their code
bases to grow without having an insight
into the structure of the code as well
as is often the proverbial big ball of
my code base it's tangled hard to
understand hard to work with harder to
change this is the key phrase right here
visualizing the structure of your code
is the first step towards improving the
editor if you can't visualize it where
you go stuff where you gonna start yeah
it's tough and so one of the things
Simon Brown does is he goes out consults
as he adds he goes out to these big
fortune 500 companies and takes the lead
engineer or lead architect please draw
me what your codebase is running out
these are actual drawings it gets one of
these is actually from
I'm not gonna call you something from
Baxter I said there's a Baxter for
really kinda heads up a lot of
development this I don't think it's what
is his there's actually somebody from a
couple it's just interests I'm not going
to say these folks are but look at this
this is somebody trying to communicate
to maybe somebody like you what their
system is I mean these are some real
masterpieces like what is this this one
here is actually my favorite it looks
like it's structured what the hell is a
functional view I've never heard of that
as an architect there's no formalized
thing call the function view there's
nothing functional about it there's no
communication is just some boxes or
whatever this one was actually drawn by
the company's CTO okay and so okay there
it is so what's going on here again our
ability to visually communicate our code
structure we kind of lost some of that
right there and so I'm gonna show you a
few tools few miles that you can use to
start into this length okay so I request
we come at it there's possibilities you
can visually communicate our code right
so let's talk about some generic models
what can I dig right into just make this
a little bit easier so there's been an
evolution of these models languages and
notations so if you've been an architect
for four years or been around it you'll
notice you'll recognize some of these
things going back and yeah this has been
talked about since the 60s even when the
invention of things such as small talk
beautiful little object-oriented
language object during a design came
around
Sharmila this was also one of the first
modeling techniques that came along that
was based on how Victorian design for
those of you familiar with Grady boots
you know who that is but this is one of
the things we would serve first started
seeing the idea of the use cases come
around
OMT one which is object modeling
technique one and two that was
introduced by Jim rumba out of MIT he
was also a friend of greedy pooches and
so there was some competition between
these two about how to model something
and then somebody else jumps in the game
creates boozy
object-oriented software engineering in
1992 and then this company called
rational Shilla they create a product
called rational rules okay
thanks people have been familiar with
that yeah okay awesome so it stands for
it stands for pretty much software
package that's rational object software
engineering and what they've done here
is these guys got together along with
another guy called
I've already got cups an eye bar is
often known as the father of the use
case is where we actually first saw a
use case come up he is actually someone
this time frame to these guys get
together and create something column
you'll know okay and then we saw the
release of you about 1.0 and then as we
started going to the data
I'm sorry calm movement you started to
see a lot of people using this language
it stands for unified modeling language
it really takes the summation of these
roles it up right here in this standard
it's really ingenious it really has a
lot of great intention behind it the
toilet you use is rows you create your
diagrams in this you guys are very close
you know how it works
but some things started to change as
time went on because this whole thing
here on this business gets complicated
there's a lot of diagrams and today
there's 17 diagrams in UML okay that's a
lot whether that was going on with it
it's it's kind of crazy but it worked at
the time because we were still very much
waterfall right it's so worked in the
design period so then we started seeing
extreme programming come about so there
was this first notion of just doing
incremental pieces of stuff and making
the design continuous thing with it and
then probably home those guys got
together and created the manifesto and
then we started seeing service-oriented
architecture and then in 2003 IBM close
advisor a show and then somehow I know
the party kind of came to an end at that
point is rub on those guys we're
fabulously wealthy after that point says
man that was great wait maybe you just
changed the damn industry right there
and now some
my zit and now just kinda puts it off to
the side because that was a pet right
there so we started that was really kind
of the last hurrah that we saw as far as
the marketing publications daily stories
about modeling languages it's kind of a
shame because we've kind of lost it
since that time here different things
have happened but you'll now continue to
evolve as a standard but the two of rows
kind of disappeared there's an expensive
thing to I remember I was at March first
we paid a quarter million dollars in our
license for it absolutely insane and
they were making money over
hand-over-fist but we had some beautiful
design walls covered with it we invested
a lot of money in it and after two
months of no code and beautiful design
we'd had it that's it okay so it's time
to look at something else but what it
got there would have got for us is if
you take a look at this right here the
arrival of modern frameworks this is
when we started seeing something like
rails spring Django symphony where are
those those are frameworks of popular
programming languages you know PHP Ruby
Java all that a lot of the design behind
that came through a lot of the design
pieces here in this language
it's a builder and now we've got
something we can let to quickly build
with we don't have to put together all
these complicated components in it so
now that enable us to go fast really
fast in our architecture in our work and
so we kind of left that behind and just
boom now we're now we're cutting out
where we're going today we're going to
talk a little bit about seaport modeling
business process notation and what's
going on with the latest
but now we've also got the arrival of
micro services which is kind of a new
design paradigm so we'll kind of talk a
little bit more about that
okay so right now we're going to focus
on question 4 +1 and the sea floor model
anybody familiar with what those are
aside from breeding the syllabus on this
talk ok it's always interesting when I
bring this up this crutch did think
because when I brought it up to my team
is this all blank faces and I had also
asked him to get up to the board and
draw something and it wasn't much
different what you saw earlier so this
is a useful thing here because they've
really
bricen we've spent things up we're gonna
do more points in our sprints because
this by the way - so what is this so
this was a model developed by Philip
Gretchen weren't irrational for a while
- he was kinda with a sales people out
there there was so many damn diagrams
and you know he just wanted to distill
this down to just a few so he could go
out there and sell rose but what he
ended up doing here is creating a really
nice abbreviated model that a lot of
people latched onto and that's why
they're called the four plus one model
it's a rather generic the other thing so
it's it's several things this scenario
considers to be a new space or a story
and around it I'm going to go ahead and
create a logical view process view both
of you in a physical view okay so I'm
going to find out structurally go it's
my code what's the process to behavior
and as user uses it the implementation
view which is awesome how I view it from
one component wait wait interacts with
third parties and stuff and then this is
my infrastructure field but what's this
stuff running okay cloud wise server
wise stuff like that so I good nice 360
around what's this use case or something
and it's great it has been really good
for describing a lot of different things
so the scenarios really helping you
capture the requirements for all the
stakeholders think of this your stories
it makes everything is around the same
and it's really key for putting together
all these views because the logical view
it's designed to really address it the
end users are concerned about what's
being used in the system if you're
familiar with UML in that logical view
we call that a class diagram in the
class diagram you just list out the
classes of your system of what you're
using
so we've captured what the class is up
process view for people are designing a
whole system those of you familiar with
UML it's called sequence diagram I'll
walk everybody through your monitor in
just a little bit just to see several
diagram okay so long know what this says
but just for this review for me this map
is over to you about development view
and say you know component diagram
okay this shows how the modules are
organized reusability physical view
again this could be our network diagram
and everything so what we do is we take
a crunched in every time we start our
spread
we'll do a crunch and say okay for these
group of stories here what do we need
them out of this okay we'll start
looking at the process for you so some
have looked at we're starting out
sequence diagram for that okay after
we've already got with the use cases
then somebody might go back and draw the
developer view
oh here's the api's i need to kind of
connect with this thing over here you
know brain trade you get my payment all
this other stuff so what kind of
straight to show that then we'll start
to extracting and what classes are we
using in our current code base and start
putting together a class diagram or
something new around that and what we do
that maybe from a conceptual diagram
first just give a holistic view of what
it is and then finally my devops guy is
always standing it says we're gonna run
this on the ec2 instance or it's such a
sensitive yes cloud right there so we
just got a rain gauge set and we got a
visually mapped right there and now
people are gonna go back to get this
reference and they had this vision of
what this looks ok one other model i
want to point out to the Seaforth
it's not explosive c4 developed by Simon
Brown this was he started using a little
bit around 2006 but really published in
2011 his inspiration was crunched in and
youma this guy was huge in the Oh mom I
remember it back in the day he really
was in the UML and stuff and then as we
saw the evolution go on with it
he felt hey there needs to be something
a little different here too so the sea
floor model it's generic just like the
crush tomorrow it's visual non
notational when I say non notational I'm
speaking in terms of like a language
like you know Melos notational bpmn is
notational we don't have to learn
notations it's just a model okay and c4
consists of a high got a feel sub
software diagrams context containers
components code that's really what this
looks like this inspiration was Google
Maps for this thing and when we talk
about context we're talking about you
know a holistic view of something when
we're talking about code we're talking
about the street level view so if we
want to work our way backwards on the
sea floor mom if I started at the at the
street view this is my code this is most
granular piece I know where it's in okay
and if I send out a lot farther here I
see that this road here is his name
maybe at KFC or limited car parts or
something that water works about okay so
i zoom out even farther and I'm sort of
looking containers okay this is code
components containers and then we're
gonna work our way over to context those
are the four C's it's a zoom model if
you will okay
it was interesting and Simon went
through this yeah the words this wrote
it it's almost like you're going into
code Basin where is this what is the
section code represent explain it to me
without the context of what the whole
system is without any type of
representation visually how do you get a
good accurate picture it is really tough
not only tell you aren't they working
with that code base for quite a while do
you know what it is okay and so we need
to have some type of context around this
and so we start looking and zooming out
here as he started using this example
this street said where does this F we
started thinking oh it's by a KFC remedy
car parts it's over by fern Valley right
here in the United States right as we
zoom that it's in Jersey you can stop by
and say I just lucky but as we look at
this fun that we found out no I need
more context in it's actually in France
it's an island off of France same thing
with the code I need to zoom out find
out where I'm at so that's how we do
this with the model the model starts out
is this take a look at what the overall
software system is put your container in
another resist your client-side web app
server web side console applications
mobile apps micro services all those
things go in in canteen okay then we
start to polarize that and take that
down to a code level is essentially
where you had with that okay I'm not
going to go into the details of how to
do it but definitely check out the sea
floor model okay also check out
correction for +1 I didn't mind make the
intent is to teach everyone had but it's
become more of awareness of how to do it
okay modeling your software
threeways architecture design often
happens ad hoc no method at all just
start going just just evolves
I'm Circle right code I should just
start going or we go with an industry
standard of modeling hey I might use a
c4 might use a crutch tin might use some
notation I'm just gonna roll my arm just
get out there and you say dope I'm gonna
draw it on the board this is kind of
what it should do and then let's start
writing something around it not
everybody might understand that but
those are kind of the three but again
it's to show that architectures are
omnipresent but not always visible okay
let's focus now on your mouth your mouth
was a quite an evolution and along with
that turn today you showed there's many
things that actually contribute it to
your mouth and Moses is so many open or
now there was different things that
contributed to so what we saw here in
the early stages many different types of
modeling techniques many different types
of models you really need to stand at a
price on this thing and that's really
what came together and that's what
grandma that's what Boosh
that's what Jakob sent all got together
and they were known as the three amigos
really sister though on putting out and
this was something that was accepted by
the object modeling group and that was a
standard and since that time we've kind
of seen new releases of you know but
there really hasn't been anything else
around it and then until we started to
see Sisson out which is a good
derivation that it allows me to do
system architecture model I've started
seeing some people use that in their
cloud architectures and that's so very
handy notation for that in the business
process modeling glue tape notation a
lot of people ask me Hank about which
version of you how are you use it it's a
good question
reusing 1.00 it's it's just it's just a
real simple thing I'll point out Anatole
we're using is Gliffy that's an assassin
confluence you can use Visio do you use
any tool like that what's interesting
about those tools is if you go take a
look at they're actually based on um I
won't point out there's a reason for
this as you monster become more complex
and things
thing that they were trying to do with
UML is if I could create enough diagrams
that depict the whole system I can
generate software with it and that's
what Road Rose was essentially trying to
do okay so if I put all these diagrams
together in your mouth it would generate
the building it sure enough you'd see
that in the demo it's interesting what
you crate was I had two paths of the MVC
okay you want to see exception handling
in that car yeah there's always one of
the things I want to see is that color
bus is that and there's where they
wanted to start taking about well let's
capture the rest set now they bloated
this thing out to just complete nonsense
it's just too much it could become so
complicated it's a gym but there are key
pieces you want to learn how to do
sequence diagram last day then component
diagram those are the three right there
okay she's where crunch time I'll get
you to a question you can also use that
with the c4 as well that's one thing
Simon Brown advocates it says hey you
know those use that your motto as well
so it's just a notation it's a visual
one other than language place of Mahalo
we need systems juice for expressing
artifacts based on a Victorian paradigm
so that works well for ever or languages
but by the three amigos I've mentioned
these guys okay now for some again known
as father abuse cases and so what is
your my own when is that it's not a
visual programming language it's a
modeling language it's what you're doing
your architecture your modeling stuff
okay it's not at or repository
specification it's a modeling language
specification you'll know at one point
oh you know about point five there's a
specifications for this modeling
language it's not a process in enables
processes okay sequence diagram we'll
see what that looks like here in a
second we're enabling things with it
okay
today's um how this was just published
that's a lot of just a neighbor is I so
agree with this with you reading for a
good seventy percent of the amount was a
useless part to sell overpriced clunky
tools
looking at irrational rows don't learn
you how to go around and repeat with
useless cast class diagrams doing the
basic so you can read a sequence day
again and learn to think this way and so
that's some pretty sound advice
actually yeah don't go through and try
to learn
whole thing don't boil the ocean just a
few diagrams is just enough to hit you a
structure and we can talk in a common
modeling language together as we got
acquired by cement they have eight
different platforms running it's even 13
different languages there's I believe
Lee said it a dozen different frameworks
going on like how on earth are you able
to talk to each a says we're kind of
screwed right now I'm like that was a
real gun with an admission of guilt
I think but I just got tight because he
already saw our presentation I said it
says that was one of our main interests
sake this discipline we got to get our
arms right because it's a big thing for
us we have a lot of people that are on
Java but they can't talk to folks over
on Rozier how do you get it to a
universal language I sit right there and
let's make it in so that's that's kind
of what Oliver is getting at here to say
just learn a few Lisa it's not human
anyway you can have this communication
tool and send stuff back and forth with
each other makes a huge difference okay
Brian I spend our time on these diagrams
you know try to keep them up today I
think it's just a tool so we can avoid
what we saw in those whiteboards earlier
is just oh my god so use cases an end
end process description the opposite
will kind of came up with this idea
includes many steps or transitions it's
not normally an individual step or
activity identified by the actor can
login the actor can print a document
printed documents a use case logon is a
use case I'm just identifying by saying
the actor can't
what's an actor that's what's causing
UML so we've also known as a user okay
but the formal way is an actor why
wouldn't they call it a user why the
court an actor sounds kind of
interesting when I design it why is that
it just was not they call it meet where
it doesn't necessarily yeah have to be a
person there could be some something
playing the role in fact I just worked
for for a Quaker Oats some years ago
when we get our use case model for them
we were doing some things with pet food
and the actor was a pet who's a dog you
know that's trying out this taste system
and it would register and suffer so yeah
good case right there doesn't have to
necessarily use case as a precondition
and action in the pros conditions so
precondition is this is something in a
system okay so
logging precondition I'm waiting and
greeted by a prompt waiting for my user
ID and my login password that's a
precondition what's the action type it
and I hit enter what's the post
condition I'm logged in to see
confirmation nurse to log in use case
right there how many said everybody's
been involved that system right it's the
most common one around
is that a design pattern you bet it's
used everywhere and when I'm at see
event no matter where I'm at no matter
what platform that design pattern exists
I could go and represent it by this I
just draw that login okay common
language so there's this thing called
essential and real use versus real use
cases so in essential use case it's a
very abstract less detailed use case
real use case very concrete more detail
when I write up this thing more
information about so you can get as
detailed as you want about your use case
when you write that thing up okay so
that's the difference between a central
use case real use cases this is a very
summarized high-level the example I just
gave there there's kind of more of an
essential these case so long and I
didn't go to the details about do I get
remember this session yeah should be
encrypted should I show the password
we're trying to get in more details okay
so that's more about very real let's
suppose that I'm just essential news
thank you buddy seen these before
yeah okay
nothing new you haven't but okay so this
is what it looks like so after I
identify use cases I start to put
together use taste dieter so I might
have my use cases by stop supervise
store staff my actor is a manager my
other actor is store staff they're gonna
be status
in my inventory report you start to get
an idea of what's going on in this
system okay this box around here is
called a system boundary and it's where
all these use cases play into we call it
the inventory system in this example so
what we're modeling here is use cases
that make up an inventory system can use
cases extend each other and including to
it you bet
all right buy stock I get payment that
includes that type of functionality buy
stock can extend the poor quality issues
the supplier can also include returning
damaged goods
I'm using some type of notation here to
show what the heck this systems supposed
to do we do this today and add till we
call them stories but the challenge we
get there's when we're using a tool like
JIRA we put all this stuff in a backlog
how do I don't get this you know it's
only as if you're doing storage Andy
okay anybody doing storing anything that
they're agile today a lot of people skip
that and that's it's also one of the
challenges out there so that's also one
of the other quests I find a product
management has really done well that
easier is is keeping some type of
backbone of what's going on with this so
we want to also think of this in terms
of a conceptual model so the
quintessential object-oriented analysis
where investigation is the decomposition
of the problem into individual steps
things we are aware we call this a
conceptual model the focus on conception
male show
concepts Association into concepts
attributes of concept I gave you two
examples down again this is relate to a
flight system so yes a flight actual
that has a date and a time
rope or concept not a software a class
or artifact so my conceptual diagram my
conceptual model that's what I want
something real not abstract ledges
flight database date/time this is a
software effect not a real-world concept
when you're abstract when you're adding
some type of conceptual diagram deal
with your real work of what does start
thinking of your software yet that's one
of the things I see is people are
starting to come from the software
developer role in our architect Amelie
when I start
like this no no no you want to talk like
this here because what is that we're
trying to learn it for the business what
is it about to user there's a user focus
here
it's product management speaks like this
business speaks like this get to that
low they don't care about flight
databases a record buried somewhere in
my soup okay okay it's important we'll
get that later but not this face okay so
that's how you wanna start with you a
distraction decomposition into classes
and so we all know a classic description
of set of things that share some
attributes methods relationships and
then you already know that drop object
during programming operation is service
second request an object different
behavior here we go let's compare the
two alright so this is my the conceptual
monitor I've got a flight of the date
number of time it flies to airport and a
name those are two potential classes
right want to get a little more concrete
with this wanting to get more stuff
where it oriented at this point so call
out your classes operation well I've got
a flight class it does have a date and
time
it's described by a flight description
what is this right here we call these
multiplicities
that's your notation so for every flight
I have many flights about one
description okay I can also have a
flight description many fight
description then Emily flies to one
Airport okay
so that's how you multiplicity early on
is you're putting this together
what are you essentially getting right
here your day tomorrow right off this
day again
it's coming right off did you identify
your classes how they relate from your
class diagram this is that they memorize
it
I could pilot first time I had put this
up to his conceptual diagram right my
lead software guy had he's really
Sheriff
he looked at that and he he knew what
these were right there he says after we
got everything done up there as far as a
conceptual Isis pretty gun with data
model just like that and a reference for
the thing who's able to go sit down and
take this thing and run with it and
start putting in a crutch tip okay and
so it was great right there and we also
got to communicate this and find out
from a business level does this logic
makes sense
why decomposition into a conceptual Momo
decomposition is it is really an
intermediary step going straight to
classes is tough
I've seen some people try to go directly
into classes as they're talking to their
product manager I think again don't
don't think like that
get your object and kind of how do you
keep it in a world with terms put that
into a model and then you want a
decomposition into classes then you can
divide that we plan time to do that with
your engineering team or yourself or
whatever okay keep it at this real level
and then decompose later okay tip if
you're struggling to find your classes
or distraction go back to the conceptual
model because you might have missed
something okay
that's where it comes from I keep
mentioning this thing about sequence
diagram and you mom it's real simple
thing shows a particular course of
events within a use case shows external
actors and interact directly the system
shows the system events that deactivate
and the ordinate events should they
follow you over the news case so
actually right here I have some type of
actor and send a message this class
fires off of it this is called a
lifeline each class has one these are
probably what methods that are in that
class
I'm calling okay and so we see the
interaction between classes how my actor
uses the system this is a sequence
diagram you know it doesn't matter what
language I'm in doesn't matter what
framework I'm in but we can all talk
this language this is one of the key
things this was what was so nice about
it you know we had a lot of people
cognizant of notations okay so getting
back to this discipline it's huge it
makes a huge impact on things so basic
sample right here cash here use cases
what buy items in our item there's my
method UPC quantity how's that how's
that have to work with the system and it
in sale make payment amount we're
starting to see how this all is enabled
by what the cashier okay so I've got a
visual representation of what's going on
with this thing one of the things we've
got in our system is is check out my
people that check out in their system
modeling that in a Cygnus diagram in
ours who's just jake onson was a lot of
stuff but what's interesting about it
was just one single method they called a
whole bunch of stuff going on in the
background had to verify had to go
through a payment and go there's if code
I mean there's all kinds of stuff
related to making it payment and then at
the very end there was a return method
that came out success also works for
front end one things that's become more
complicated here's our front end we
didn't used to have some of the front
end complexities for a while I mean some
of the front-end frameworks you guys got
all the react angler view and burst and
for what century change Allah every
eighteen months or sometimes it's just
drive me crazy
it's so JavaScript at the end of day but
why some a friendly you got to look on
NPM it's a wild OLS there's a bunch of
stuff going on out there wouldn't be
nice if you could actually model the
front end on this and kind of reduce
some of the complexity and make it work
with your framework that's how that the
sequence diagram will also do so I gave
you an example of your to of of how we
can essentially have the user piece
going in with this and then communicate
with the backend application whatever's
going on here I could expand this out to
multiple classes words check login
validate login all this is coming back
from this is probably what JavaScript
right here okay what's going on so I'm
modeling the front end at the end of it
yeah say these databases again same guy
at the same time pad area sequence
diagram okay let's talk about this other
diagram class diagram so it illustrates
the specification for our software
classes shows definitions for the
classes identifies the classes
participating in software solution and
shows the class relationships that's an
interesting thing when I take a look at
ways large code bases that's like my
first things you're kind of going after
it's like what is this class
what's it about this is also point where
you see some the worst design software
like what was it thought bi creating
this class and look what it's evolved
into some monstrosity I came together
fagala without a visual representation
to tell me what the heck is going on
that is damn difficult well particularly
can you imagine coming out of a 12-week
dev bootcamp and your background was
originally I know
archaeology that's what you got your
degree in you don't have much of a
systems background and yet you're
wanting to get into rural the software
you love it so you did this bootcamp
that you paid if I go through boot camp
okay don't you pay 20 grand for and it's
still tough to find you once you land
the job you get put in this huge
codebase and now you try to figure out
these classes that you figured out your
dev bootcamp in it just doesn't make any
sense at all for a long time you always
having to go to help because who knows
this
who knows hello this is running let's
probably they've been the guy or gal
that has been in this code base for a
number of years it's go working with it
they've travel to all the different
places in the code base it's still
upward in their head because they
haven't created any of this stuff yet is
their job secure who cares how secure is
the company at that point is that person
walks it out you're just now doubled
your butt my own money you're gonna
spend here to try to get some people up
to speed trying to figure out what's
going on this is an investment over time
this is your vitamins right are you
taking your vitamins remember then I
said at the beginning it's almost as if
you just ended up on the alert a was
that person walked out the door on the
outbreak days oh man we should have
invested our vitamins I hope that makes
sense it's kind of goofy analogy using X
or scenario and the crutch to write buy
items look what all is involved with buy
items I got a store class I got a post
class they're gonna sail try to Kerala
class what makes them use each other
what looks in what houses is showing
interactions it shows the multiplicities
this is the class diagram and you'll
know for buy items I'm also showing
instances variables methods all these
different things what is it about that
that's interesting about
this class it's got methods but it
doesn't have any did it yeah nothing no
same thing with this one product catalog
it's got a method for specification than
that day how about this one product
specification it's only got feelings
yeah but no methods I can do that just
maybe you looked at the code kit and now
I know that I really don't have too much
about prio what language is in I
immediately got that from this
extrapolation their huge help new job
but know what's going on this code base
okay so that's kind of the power of this
thing remember the statement I showed
earlier says don't like I was saying
don't waste all your time with all these
useless class diagrams in a way he was
kind of right because when you Mel was
out it was not uncommon that I would see
a class diagram with over 300 classes on
it and it looked like the biggest
spidering whatever I couldn't begin a
follower that was some way that did not
say I'm not just kind of oh yeah I did
this and just start writing up
everything you got to do it in chunks
you gotta do a small pieces and that's
where the iterative process comes today
it's back to the Simon book called just
enough just enough to get through this
right you have to do that great big
thing component diagram this is the last
one we're going to cover it's useful
because it gives us a high-level
architecture of what will be built
doesn't wreck addictive verify that
systems require functionality is being
implemented as a video about to play
next components are now strictly logical
design type constructs they actually
call this constructs now but since we're
on 1.0 I like calling component diagrams
if you use Gliffy or Visio guess what
the little maybes going to have one for
you know it's gonna call component
diagram I'm gonna go back to that use
case diagram that you saw with the actor
and says use case ding what version you
go metal is that one anybody else
the answer is it's all but that's where
it came from this one yeah yeah yeah one
covers so much from the beginning and
everything what was added later are
Nemo's additional diagrams he gives that
to that generative software for
to generate code base and everything so
we have relationship diagrams we had
class split diagrams they got insane
everything to gloated no we just need
the basics okay just the basics of this
okay an artifact would be a physical
unit and final gym modules yeah we're on
a run or else and so it's not common for
me just to put some gems up in a
component a graph show me how this gem
this is what the internationalization
gem which shows how it works with my
home page okay so that's why I Jim does
18 in similar things that you jump some
other things in PHP so this is a
component diagram and in the Kapow world
we have something called vendor portal
application so if I'm Nikki I'm a vendor
I've got it place you can come and have
your event if I'm Regal theater I've got
a place she didn't have your event I'm
considered a vendor so I will go into
the portal entering name information
one of our key customers that we've got
is Regal theaters a lot of people last
December for the release of star wars
wanting to have their office sales price
associated with that so we partnered up
with regal because it's really tough to
get people in the theaters on a Monday
afternoon or Tuesday afternoon or
theaters empty so when we show up saying
hey we got a deal for you we got people
looking for space but they would love to
go to during that time of day and had to
business me this hell let's let's hook
up and so on the release of steroids we
had 92 events across the country all
booked at the same time for that release
party that's what it's going on I've
been there portals you can sign up for
this thing so you created you can almost
describe what's going on with our
software right here so yeah you go in
and create a group this is a form you
submit there's a can
you can jam anybody familiar with rails
that's your authentication okay get your
authorization that's what allows
authorization and gentes kind of agenda
controls that used to be called can't
can't jam the first version I was caught
can't we're all placing bets on what
version floor is going to be I'm saying
quad-cam salesforce.com yeah it's also
part of this Google Maps
well yeah where's your where's your
venue at yeah Italian to Google Maps
with this too right that's what I'm
showing this I'm using the API and group
information how Salesforce you signed up
as a vendor with this you have a master
service agreement yep connected here
that's also part of the form that I'm
sitting right there so yeah there's a
whole flow about component wise I'm
talking API is here I'm talking gems I'm
talking difficult points ok ok so what
are the three diagrams again sequence
class component those are three need to
know that gichan's were approached it
basically what a use case says you're
use stories today same type of thing ok
in that question diagramming a physical
view there's a is anybody using a cloud
craft cloud craft is used for modeling
your AWS infrastructure you can actually
have like a three-dimensional thing it
shows all the components you're using on
AWS and each compiled and we'll show you
a costing of how much it's costing you
each month you can make the entire
drawing of your a tennis system on cloud
craft ok
we've taken cloud craft and we put that
in a crushed in physical model we just
take a snippet
oh this one's running on the ec2
instance for Gemini listening where
search pop it in there that's associated
we know where this coding money that's
another thing coming into a large code
base where's all this stuff aligned
we've got seven different instances out
of AWS it's splitting up this
application right give it like why are
they all there and the guy starts to
drop me one of these dash lines
couldn't be a follow what's going on
show me this no it's a show me a
physical view boom right there when I've
just hired an engineer a few weeks ago
to come on board
you just look that's what I said
describe the system for me after 8:00
it's reviewing these things he said so
we've got seven instances we've got
redundancy because they repeat these
went through whole thing so how did you
know that this is when it's all in
crushes like you like you mean like
physical data this is it again this is
what I'm trying for infrastructure we've
got Jenkins and ec2 that we've also got
a zip file that's uploaded here to our
s3 bucket AWS elastic Beanstalk for my
load balancing okay how it triggers
those are all part of physical
deployment diagram okay so let's talk a
little bit about time okay
so design patterns this is this was
something that is very popular early
years and on that timeline you'd see it
start to evolve somewhere in the 80s and
then 90s patterns became very popular
and then priests in is a turn of century
came around y2k or so we'd start to hear
components being used these were all the
things we knew about building software
free soon as we put a bunch of
components together the diagrams you
start to see an entire framework that
was a genesis that we we've got general
rails and things like that
that's how it came about so patterns is
what we used to work with and today we
still use pattern pretty different way
there's the very simplified so in
software engineering a design pattern is
a general reusable solution to a
commonly occurring problem in software
design design pattern is not a finished
design that we transform directly in a
code rather than it is a description of
template try to solve a problem I can be
used in many different situation it's
this repeatability
okay that Japan I can use them in
different areas logon right there's a
pattern okay that occurs in many
different places
okay patterns originate is an
architectural concept by Christopher
Alexander around late 70s that's where
this came about
okay gof what does that stand for
Ganga Florence and some of you guys are
familiar with that so this is well these
things again back to earlier years of
object-oriented design designers they
they gained popularity through this book
actually called design patterns it's
really about making object-oriented
software and this kind of reusable type
of thing but this so-called Gang of Four
and so the books and authors are gamma
how Johnson and I'd always see students
say yeah those are the game for this
book became very popular and it's still
reference today it contains a lot of the
software patterns that are in our
systems to be quite frankly we don't
have to worry about it's baked into the
framework but that's how like systems
got put together so every once a while
here some a reference a gang and for
patterns a nice guy interesting slate
somebody understands this and I've
really studied it I saw patterns are an
interesting thing because there's
touring that's involved with this their
supporters know why do patterns okay
design patterns can speed up the
development process and predicting by
providing tested proven development
paradigms seems pretty simple in concept
critics why not do better well they're
viewed as workarounds for core features
missing in a language language where
sometimes viewed as a lack of good
abstraction and a barrier to creativity
well if I keep using this same paradigm
Goethe am I kind of stuck in that design
type of thinking do I necessarily have
to think of login as login all right I
just walk up to it you start using
somehow or another I'm already good I'm
authenticated I didn't have to log yeah
it's stretching your mind to a different
type of thing yes the argument with it I
myself I still I think I walk up tonight
keyless car yeah that's a nice practice
and I'm student
keep okay ha ha
something that turning it in there but
that's that's the idea I think most
sites have a better liking that with it
this here is saying hey productivity it
ok but I want to create stuff right now
and I'm going to use the components that
are available to me there is somebody
saying I want to think outside the box
I don't we get stuck into say they're
against without yes which I don't think
we'll need a bigger argument for
patterns as communication definitely
alright cuz you know if you're all using
the same terminology you don't have to
go to the white cottages you can just
say what really pumps up they have the
system's talk to each other okay I now
know immediately what you need if you
know what the parents are right versus
well I'm gonna open the socket and we'll
some of us will negotiate right you
could that's the anti pattern because
you have to go through the description
you know the drug as a good point you
really bring up because think about 2001
that's when we had the 17 guys getting
the ski lodge have come up with the
manifesto what was popular at that time
patterns gang before this it was it came
for that that was it
those guys were thinking in terms of
time and they did exactly what you were
you're talking about right there
there's ability to communicate with that
fast forward eighteen years different
kind of thinking going on now yeah it's
just we don't think really in terms of
so much of that if we do I hear the term
pattern almost being abused at some
times somebody calls something
impediments it's not it's just a
programming paradigm or something
so anyway three pattern types so there's
creational pattern structural patterns
behavior crash there's a really the main
three may be familiar with creational
patterns at once created they create
object for you rather than having to
instantiate objects directly this gives
you program a bit more flexibility in
designing which object you need to be
created for a particular case structural
patterns this is getting back to our
class and object composition how
inheritance is use behavioral planners
specifically concerned with the
communication between objects those are
the main three pattern types I'm paying
so creational patterns structural
patterns behavior patterns logging which
kind is that which one would that be you
got it
yeah behavior that's something I'm
interacting with its going with the
system that's a behavioral pattern its
architectural review board any you guys
have a record textual review board
furtive it okay person saying yes why do
an ARB Architectural Review
well ultimately we want out the line
design with the company business global
strategies and objectives for the
quality of our products find the
technical design standards policies and
principles for the company overall
something I started at Capel was in ARB
Architectural Review Board when I came
in on a grooming session went for three
hours I think my gosh that is crazy I'm
a grooming session it what are we
talking about in here now you've served
as soon as I started listening in
there's a lot of discussion about
architecture and design going by they're
kind of blending grooming with
envisioning and it was a just a whole
melting pot of stuff going on with it
right there so I said let's pull that
dialogue out in something as a focus
group and let's think about our overall
holistic view of system architecture and
application in architecture you call sis
art in that part for short so when we
get our architectural review board
together we meet once a month and
charlie
we've got a few developers that are in
it I got one person for QA I got one
person from DevOps
these folks all are interested in
architecture it's part of their career
roadmap and I've worked out with them
they want to talk about sis art and a
part and what we can do to guide the
direction of our system design it so we
don't have to talk about this just
abstractly and some grooming
and a July everything so gets focus too
but this is not just me putting this
together there's actually a format
around the saying this is where arabes
became very popular MIT is probably the
most popular one and this is the format
we follow there's a couple links to this
all I have in the presentation for this
really good mit European guidelines but
this one I was at I work for bright star
as well we also have a review about
companies have these they put some of
that focus on this omnipresent but not
visible type of thing it's a little bit
focus on this thing so we can start to
guide how our design is done anything
that's great we also part of this we
have an issues long they were always
reviewing to something structurally
comes up it was put that in here be
reading this month or hey I want to talk
about something a sea floor model right
as we call board with C then they're
using scaled agile framework safe that
has something called architectural
runway were you doing in a blurs and you
do functions built just enough design
consume built design consumed that's
called architectural runway it's safe
and that's why the things we introduced
in the area that was new for a lot of
folks right there it's getting back to
that pencil principle of design just
enough for that not really well spelled
out in the original manifesto but
certainly the skill of agile framework
we're starting to see that spell that
they want that piece in their big
question mark is what are you doing
during on it that's a lot of stuff we
just talked about these are already out
because they kind of sound a little
corporate issue but these are really
actually just taken right out of the MIT
portion their short term goals or you
still want to create this with your
lines that create architectural roadmaps
its support your business long time
prevent framework love achieve a
platform that can be easily you know
maintenance okay being strategic being
visionary with okay reduce a long term
technical debt that's also something
that just
because two is like at what point do we
need to take another technical how come
I avoided one thing I've noticed is we
started doing this for the past six
months
put that smaller design piece in there
I've no see the amount of debt that
piles on man is that really shrunk
because we're being very strategic in
thinking ahead about our design and
putting it out there we don't have to
just patchwork something along just to
get to another place okay so we can
think about a plan ahead on the thing
right there and say nope
it's out for the spread cuz we don't
have enough design along okay cool we
have to patchwork and say well we'll
catch up on that later just call it
technical debt let's go ahead and build
it safe oh my god it just builds up and
it's just crazy crazy so and this keeps
our technology costs in line - that's a
big thing with the air beat we have
everybody but you guys haven't awsm you
running on a DBS you gotta eat it yes
bill is your go google bill what's the
other Vemma I think is for the
healthcare one or they hate to be pricey
we need to be pricey you could spend
easily hundreds of thousands of dollars
millions of dollars out there in the
cloud but how do you know you you're not
purchasing too much how do you make sure
it's right make sure it's lined up this
is one thing that you're everybody can
do find out this is re always big my my
sister and it's it's a key thing because
you start small or plan big you don't
turn it up the wall the ocean focus on
quick wins
show the results really and often with
the end of mine and they create a
maturity roadmap it's probably okay
we're talking enterprise architecture
and frameworks when you think in terms
of enterprise frameworks like cities
think of enterprise and architecture is
a city
portfolio architectures of street system
architecture is the Builder
okay so it's okay the architecture will
continue that's one way of framing this
in terms of that enterprise architecture
enterprise architectures are strategy to
minimize ITM business mistakes many
competing perspectives approaches RTA
here to keep me it's really no single
agreed upon enterprise
architecture standard like we do in a
park and park we got um oh we've got
some models out there since aren't not
quite the same way with enterprise
architecture so this is a key period you
want to focus upon and so that's why
we've got these things called
architecture frameworks and so just like
software frameworks that are enterprise
architecture frameworks and these
frameworks help us be productive and
creating and managing our designs main
frameworks to choose from we used to
talk up I really like talk specifically
toga idiom the stands for in the Open
Group architectural framework
application design model okay I'll show
what that looks like here a little bit
some folks with ITA ITIL Zachman was
popular in the early 90s or something
it's more like a grid a 12-piece grid
and shows you a make your decisions
based on your enterprise somebody had
asked me what this one is
this is Department of Defense
architectural framework this is for
software as they write it - so they
follow that framework or as well so
there's a milspec
on their enterprise architecture and a
lot of the older systems even that the
the missile systems are built in or base
their software follow this type of
enterprise architecture so we use toga
milkman group architectural framework
with Cartland version 9.1 with this
anybody from a moment they might use
Intel Gough just first first time you've
heard of it yeah why this doesn't get
the airplane should they this [ __ ]
back today so it's key because it's the
go-to framework for enterprise
architecture and this group kind of
maintains it what you do with this thing
this is how we run it in the air be is
women I start the architectural review
board session we've got I have a
simplified version of this because by
these Gators still kind of knew this so
I take it out of Peters things but we
start with an architectural vision of a
slide on that said what do we want to
work on well have something called
current state future state technology
vision governance you can just walk
through those and that's what you're
reviewing in your
he would say hey here's a hot state of
the system here's what we need to
address
here's future state should we scale -
what are we expanding to say all these
reviewing this in every ARB we go
through this thing it's called the
togepi and architectural design every
time it makes a big difference - because
well yeah governances we've got here is
actually coming out of Europe which is
the GDP are okay from here with that one
yep right there part G Toyota that's
where you want to address that okay so
standards like that are key so we always
keep those in the highlights any time
somebody wants to bring him a new
technology introduce it into our stack
it goes through this whole thing right
there let's let's run through the gamut
let's see what happens if it makes sense
for it and we what we end up doing with
our stories is actually making design of
required artifacts they would just get
scheduled in they get pointed in
schedule so we stayed on the 1 week
sprint but you wouldn't maybe consume
that artifact until the next the next
press right and I'm wondering it said
reasons against that or as you just
decided to kind of in some way will make
up spent two weeks and your front loader
those tasks in the early party scene
early party yeah and for that reason so
we give ourselves some architectural
runway is it caught in and said you know
scaled agile chocolate so you want to
create runway so we're actually planning
after well got things going on for the
very first one we did I put in the
design for
put in and then we started from there
itself as we go to the next sprint the
design work that we're doing we already
did it in the previous so that helps
with product management to plant what's
coming out and that's these everything
that's just way I kind of decided to do
it there I noticed in the one week's
rent it was on a lot of time to discuss
and get it arms right and the chunks
ended up being so small just forward I
had I wanted people to also learn this
too so it gave some time to adapt to
this because this was something kind of
quick and given how much points were
rolling over each week it became
apparent to me what we're trying to bite
stuffing this but too large a chunk so
we didn't know how to decomposition we
didn't do my addy cop stuff that's
because we really didn't know how to
design really did not it chump this up
into a visual representation of children
oh let's just do this put a crunched in
around this thing and let's see where
that ends up right there find out the
dependencies officer
find out what happens and oftentimes see
a story map okay so the dependencies on
the story minute big story mapping is a
cyclic backbone in it a backlog is
holistic view of things and this is
where your stories come out of instead
of suit of cards does we're just guys
some of the reason it's no one
particular thing but you know if it's
working for your growth now if you if
you feel that's enough time you get
depends what your deliveries is to be
but we've had to split things up but
I've gotten away from I'll tell you that
because I don't like having some
partially completely because that's only
a partially design I'll first ask that
we can design a good chunk of it in this
in this sprint let's not start going
until we got a good feel of it we're
going to the next branch and continue on
with the design that would pick up it
might be just enough right there okay
let's go for it let's go ahead and build
it at that point there were you know
good left hanging in the middle of
something where we didn't get to all of
our design thinking oh and then there's
no requirement that comes in
change your mind so they've kind of
prevented that so that's why I stretch
the out of it for others so given what
that more women didn't want to go three
weeks or four weeks we're cousins my
anxiety for people that are coming over
one week for one but it's it also I
think that week just seems to work just
right for them for what are that company
was doing did you think
where's that bread store we had a three
three week we start with a four weeks
bread there's a lot of people coming out
for waterfall to say oh my god that's
that it's like I can't will you make it
go longer are you trying to get to this
well yeah okay
I have people with in the sprint do
cover if I have something I'll split out
into a couple says it seems like we've
got one area that's just for a project
really called project intake and then
another it was vendor portal if that
team on vendor portal wants to work as a
comment cuz you already know what the
work is gonna be in everything you know
confident your time management as well
as what's coming up and what's expected
then that's fine you're working but
you're still working in the context of
it and release date on things the
biggest issue I I find with doing the
Kanban really comes down to time
management does that find some people
will just crank I mean just give him
work and then go back to the clock give
me more give me more anymore I've also
found it's just a perfect weight for a
slacker to be in there just
yeah I did mine and it just it depends
I've had developers in fact not just
development well side of the factory
floor where you've seen combat implement
when I first came into engineering like
they came in as a design engineer
working in manufacturing and we'd have
people on the factory floor it was a
Kanban system I'd see people out there
taking breaks galore not really getting
the work done but you know I'd see some
people out there cranking and running
out of parts and stuff so it became a
management issue of really can you
manage the time to make sure that that's
effective in terms of the design around
Kanban yeah design as much as you can
for however far we want to go no mind
you I don't want you designing for the
next couple of weeks on it no how far do
you up do you want to meet her the
combat that's going out so think ahead
then so as I work with those guys in the
on the Kanban piece it's really metering
the designer you're still thinking in
terms of releases there's something in
terms of the releases so maybe I'm
grouping of a function as you put it
together in your story mapping ok I want
to take this segment here and what
Kanban all for that
how much design do I have on it ok you
can still segment it and then you just
don't have this formalize we're gonna
release on this date you know have a
retro and because that nature so again
time management kind of the key piece on
that one things I I work with Artie
Buccos remember the comedy the 7 Habits
of Highly Effective People very popular
series right there the time management
tool in there still very popular
today it's the four quadrants what is it
important not important Virgen not
urgent you want to work on things that
poor good a virgin you want to move
things that are pretty and important
stay on that this mismanagement by
crisis continue to move them in two
important but not urgent some folks just
really struggle it's a time management
think so just giving a mentor right
there help prioritize the stories
and kitchen earlier about you know
getting your team together and I might
go out to the board because that one you
or one you don't ever think that and
then the other one come up no he said is
it an architect know what what does the
steep would have been for example of
developers coming in and taking on some
of those responsibilities or is this
design work primarily handled by
architecture and then unset word good
question yeah it's really good question
because where is this architectural role
at today what do we call an architect
today so I come in I'd see people that
have got that title architect how I
asked him about question tow God okay
well tell me what architecture is to you
and for some of them as we're looking at
Rao's well instead of creating
everything in this one particular folder
we decided to add another structuring
here so we can put our config files into
this section here so we've changed the
overall architecture of how we work with
rails
Megan hits architecture are you again so
yeah thank you okay but no so when I
started with is when we do career pool
when I do Career Planning with folks
like what does it be wanting to be I'll
pick out the developers say I'm
interested in being an architect and
then I'll sit down with them and won't
go over at least these two of these guys
it's like what we did here that this
presentation was a very first one I gave
to them right there and so there's head
exploded I think I said let's just go
into some baby steps so let's first
start off we're doing a sequence diagram
so one day I had him who's been there a
while he knows a lot of software and his
head he's a he's offering to be the one
talking since I I just go up to the
board can you put a sequence diagram
I hope walk you through so it's parent
it's architectural appearing so I'm I'm
kind of instructing how do you do the
sequence diagram kind of do the
component diagram and then getting this
in the classes and what's interesting
that is you know when we're changing
something in the code base hearing those
words classes are there he already knows
the structure there a message down
I'm putting getting on board in a
language it the rest of the developers
can understand so what I'm doing is I'm
picking up somebody who has an interest
in this discipline going farther than it
they don't know it right off the bat so
there's some coach or a contemporary
coach it goes on with it it doesn't take
long it doesn't take long and if they're
really interested though do it and I
still have to prod someone to get to the
board because there's and I'm real
confident in a couple of things one is
still getting comfortable with just the
two trying to figure out the problem
itself because here's this big ball of
mud of color just and then there's a lot
to juggle everything so as we continue
to keep one it's something you're
building it's a living thing just like
your cookies your design is a living
thing you're building upon it
now you're going to create a moment a
day just little pieces yeah after a year
you look back on this and collect all
this yeah pretty good view what's going
on you've also got better I heard his
hearing chops without a diagram
something everybody on my team knows
what the question is that we had
yesterday the weekly team meeting I had
and I'm gonna be hiring more engineers
them we're looking at bringing on eight
more engineers for our team because
we're gonna scale the power to a fit and
sea level 1500 customers we've got scale
to 25,000 one of those customers spent
almost as much as all those 15 minutes
over 25,000 so we got a scale people and
so they bring people on board there
would be a key piece and so silence I
need to get spectators to just look for
individuals that you know that see this
is a potential your career path or maybe
even not that but just show up a desire
to think a little bit differently in
other words you can be a coder
and it just kind of encouraged an
adventure that is that's what I'm gonna
say right now a lot of times I think
people are comfortable just having
everything handed to do that without
dude you'll be part of the analysis so
that how do you be part of the ownership
of that product that you're building
understand it yeah it's like this the
statement and Simon drama yeah if I
can't visualize visualize it then
hunters am I going to be able to improve
it and along those lines at some point
you can't have every developer in here
in your bar and work at the
architectural meetings right so yeah if
that mechanism for disseminating what
you've what your group comes up was to
the masses so it's bacon I was curious
about and I know I asked you this before
but last for this group do you put
things into motion to make sure like
this the end the source code is somehow
linked back to the architecture as you
know like is it hidden in handy if you
make him put stuff in the heaviness this
this this this piece of code was was
generated based off of this you amount
allow or that sort of thing or in
another thing along those lines is if
you're programming in a world where you
you have to you have to conform the
specifications like they data
transmission specification and stuff
like that do you include those engineer
diagrams and you just someone you know
if you provide an automatic anism for
actually linking it to the source code
it's questioning the fact yeah
I'm done that's like those those are all
good and they're relevant and related to
each other because it it's an important
piece how it manages what's to it for
this so I would go about it is juror
okay that's that's our main nail into
all right application lifecycle
management tool we've also got
confluence I meant we were using Griffey
so those diagrams that she's some of the
ones that you see up did I did those in
glyphic and so after we go to the board
I'll take a picture I'll take a picture
of thing then I'll go ahead and enter it
in a Gliffy by using the amount notation
that's English now create that into the
digitized thing it's just something I'm
trying to get some guys up to speed
where they can do they're able to draw
it up in the whiteboard so we've got to
get to where they can use on i'm glyph
and why don't when he sees he's got to
be pretty good with it so that's that's
one step so get in get it into Gliffy
now once it's in Gliffy i can tie that
into journal because it's it's the same
platform right it's pretty by asking
stack so i can put a link to the Gliffy
diagram in the story right there so as
i'm looking and reading the straight
okay i'll click on the diagram i did
maybe the architects went through and
now see how this is designed so it's
it's carried with it
same thing with the UX guy to his comps
are also in the story too we use figma
for aux so we have a cops in there sila
what's being followed in history is this
really center and juror okay so i've
made a link to my Gliffy diagram which
has a crunch tune in it okay
it's got my ux gems and if you've got
standards in there then that's gonna be
part of the story right that's in there
and I could put a link into something
that's probably a confluence that I've
got linked up and I know that that's how
we kind of tight together I don't know
if you guys saw that was it to through
heinous three with someone or two and
three weeks ago
Atlassian released a product called
Gliffy project basically an announcement
this has gotta be the coolest things
I've seen in let us think it's they
understand this gap quick talk to him I
don't go to these engineers I feel like
where you going with your prices we're
going after design say because IBM's
going after
we see this gap and so they came out
with glyphic project what glyphic
project is doing is you can take a
diagram that you created and Gliffy or a
picture then I took a whiteboard just a
JPEG create a hotspot on the diagram or
the JPEG then hotspot
I can tie to a car to a story injuries
it's drag and drop right on to the
visual right there and so as I've got my
use case diagram cuz they've got my
class diagram whatever I'm going to be
work on any type of diagram up there I
can put a hotspot on that diagram
I literally drag is spread number card
so that the story number on top of that
thing so what I got there is something
to visually tie it together right there
which is kind of cool
the weight which really tell me about
with lastly did this is when you read
the literature about what they released
we try and dress at o4 for project
management then they show this flowchart
I an amazing the project okay
I feel business flow chart shows how
you're dragging your stories over into
your the project but when you go watch
the video that the promoting this
singlet there's the real telling thing
it's only a minute it doesn't shine it
it shows a system architecture diagram
system architecture day mind you this is
a physical view in a crunch - they took
the sis art diagram of somebody that's
got their eight mes diagram and showing
that as the diagram that they're
dragging their spread stories into and
it's pretty cool because my DevOps
person is gonna be sitting there sin
oh jeez hurt might ask for what we're
building right there and he continues to
build up on that diet for future state
but what we identified the toga at then
so he's got his diagram
he's got a sprint with all the stories
visually tied to the hot spots in the
thing and then the product manager can
look like this st. Tuesday oh this were
all that's running it the whole thing
ties together like that
pretty cool stuff that's the only a are
meant to allow
now that has it to where you a couple
together visual with the actual
assignments on top of it and it carries
it through itself is a great pride gets
up my it was able to talk my management
into saying look let's get let's make a
pilot on this and assist sometimes we're
gonna get a shot see what happens here
I've also tried pushed for a backlog too
and that the story exactly so what's the
documentation yeah that's the question
what's the documentation so is it is the
documentation a diagram that we created
as a documentation a story that we
previously worked on what's tying all
this together towards not dated we all
have to stay up on the maintenance is
that is that the angle injera when you
do your code okay you can link to the
release right to the vena Jenkins the
repository so you can tie right to the
reef on it and see where that's head I
don't get up so it's really such Angus
but it's it's get up so you can tie in
to get and see what's the code attached
to that story that's got that design
diagram and there this guy's maybe the
UX portion on there now as time goes on
before updating stuff then go back to
them yeah I can go back to it if it
changes in a big way that I don't want
to go back to redo that thing that's
fine I'm just going to go to the most
recent there and I can still put a link
in reference to prior so they're always
linked some way so you can always go
back into the higher in the history but
I think that's really what we want to
see
we're just saying originated from who's
the Genesis or the thinking that got us
to this code base that's something we
don't have right okay nice big ball of
mud I don't have a let me he's decided
to go this path
as time goes on you start to see the
linkages for each one of those things
it's the most recent one that said today
my UX person that does our UI state he's
he was pretty excited that this
acquittee project because he said I got
components I reuse all the time and
we've got a lot of repetition here I'd
love to be able to call those out on
this thing so I can find one a new one
isn't it
everything so and as one becomes
obsolete you can start to flag those
things I met right on his actual comps
that's that's the system I would
recommend also taking like that Simon
Brown book just enough he also has some
good ideas there's no this point one way
of doing the same anything that we're
going back to what we were doing
waterfall that is we made these
beautiful diagrams for the past two
three months
everything and they were gonna keep up
on this thing because we're not going to
touch this is good we're gonna make code
from that's three plus everything and
it's all day to know it's continuous of
living breathing thing with it so your
ALM tool is what's key JIRA confluence
get all these are key things Italian I
said so just to be clear as they're
providing me some like if you're writing
in JavaScript it's given you a header
you can actually plant in that piece of
source code that said this is them that
you know here here's your architecture
documents that support why this was
written this way and there's many under
code it's all related through Dale
that's right it's related through your
JIRA ticket that you used to create that
JavaScript oh it still cheap I came
against that ticket
that's so you know all the disks that
when you're referencing the ticket in in
a gif transaction so yeah yeah that's it
and you can go back and they get reap on
see what was deleted what was added
that's a great tool to I think the last
thing had a competing product and
biggest after it's about fish I competed
against the repo you could see what was
changed but giving up doesn't know yes
but for me and never solve the designs
are from using JIRA I'm still the thing
that's the question you were kind of
getting
it's the doc just lives in the Jura
tickets you can never find them again
and as soon as you add new features
where's it at
we're you can't go didn't you work on
this code somewhere over here what was
the ticket number there's the guy who
knows all the absolutely right in which
are you gonna go is all right keep
mentioning story mapping it's creating
that thing called a backbone mystery
matter
there's a guy named Pat they come up
with this thing and you guys got to go
back there because you'll see where
we're at with it that's a product
management future that's going after its
product management do you know what to
find build on that - I work in like a
very larger soft board we're gonna see
if in Seoul you know there's like
hundreds of thousands of git
repositories and different software
artifacts in life I don't like I guess
is how how do you maybe have to put
already enterprise architecture
functional organs helping keep that
we're gonna ask is it especially if
you're a new person part of the first
immediate problem is just understand
what are the different software
artifacts and which one is relevant to
the particular problem I'm supposed to
be solving right now just like even
begin to discover where documentation is
or of what I need to know or Pauline
interacts with all their artifacts - it
sounds like just a pretty good-sized
team that came up with that much so it's
that's it a good sense
engineering development group or is that
something that's going to accumulate
over time
yeah well I work at it so there is like
both novice engineer it's both it's good
over time and this team as well so how
are you managing the scrums how you
managing
attacks that are you keeping him y'all
in just so as you do your scrubs I know
that I benched the scaled agile
framework there's less dad there's a
couple of these others
thanks guys a friendly property because
it's using this architectural runway
keep managing it so as you have been
doing a scrum of scrums yeah varying
results where the tools they use how
they managing that pieces are working
with total product management and is it
kind of points out there a lot if it's
something it's worth you only as Goods
what you're gonna be getting in that's
what it is
with all this the real week's fighting
in here is I don't have good
requirements behemoths are they
extremely vague how far am I gonna get
yeah but it's also good to cuz I'm not
gonna start going so I don't know enough
about it is much more difficult to write
software first for something that's just
generic as opposed to something that's
very specific
yeah if I know the details on it then
it's a heck of a lot easier to write
thing it gets back to the Mona Lisa
versus diagram picture versus Daggett
very explicit what is this view showing
me everything that's what the diagram is
going to be attacked yeah but managing
it that whole repository of those
decorative as you want to call them
design documents if you're working with
stories for what are those coming from
is there some type of a master document
that or no Boone Rd business
requirements document that the Krait
management's working with and that's
kind of coming from there in I always
curious to see how to manage it yet
there is a notation if you notice that
was on that framework called BPMN
business process notation business
process modeling notation
there's a notation actually coincides
with you'll know and so that was one one
of the ways they wanted to tie together
you about with product management say
Frank management's got its own notation
stick that ties in and I can marry all
this together with this they're having
product managers
time for that thank Kalman this many
fingers it just says it's a discipline
very real problem I don't have a quick
answer for ya one of other questions
that it is I guess some of the friction
that I always felt when I was studying
in the mountains a little bit and then
later is an immediate assist to get you
in on specific problems like a lot of
the notation seem very coupled to like a
classical inheritance based like
object-oriented programming paradigm
works offered oh yeah and it as soon as
you sort of get outside that mapping the
design actually your translating design
sniffing kind of starts to break down a
little bit
or even if it even if you can follow
through it doesn't really necessarily
need like a clear simple and connotation
so I'm curious sort of like how that how
you would address that are going are
your keys
I'm trying to see if I sign I understand
how that's been asked so what you saw
was something I was coming out of an
object-oriented nature right what if
you're not dealing with an object or any
things let's say it's no functional
program like like the elixir there's
something okay you are in Phoenix spring
so the elixir being a function I'm
typing how's this stuff work because the
attorney things based on objects how
does that go forward you don't have this
notion classes well what is it that we
have a functional program it functions
right that's one thing so yeah that
allows we can absolutely break this down
into functions as well if you don't want
to call it class I took a notation it's
any elixir modeling that I've done I
didn't tell the class I just put it as a
function then here's all the things with
it so that's that's how I adjusted it
we're trying
think so functionally I get SIA that
sits put together all this was a genesis
out of as you saw the timeline from
small talk that's how we package stuff
up but that paradigm you know that's not
the only matter it's a great example
what are you doing something I get how
you can adapt it it's still a structure
it's still a notation you're still
trying to convey an idea because the
game game back to the very beginning of
it what is your product is an architect
provision the vision of where it is and
you're just trying to communicate that's
all the diagram is done no more that's
it so just communicate what that is as
you can see from all the scribbles on
the board really struggle with that yeah
so just try to standardize
yeah good question very good question
yeah so what's the next language going
to look like if it's not function or
either you know will it still it still
had to go about solving a problem
visually capturing yet yeah no probably
a good opportunity to start another
technical modeling language if you're
interested give me a call if you think
that's important for that cuz those got
really wealthy small small
and they noticed a couple of the slides
you mentioned out of it d-daddy yeah
yeah so and triple da dee dee dee
whatever the guys says design-driven
the main driven design and then what you
were referring to was what we call it
conceptual diagram so no decomposition
it it's before I go into thinking about
code before I go into thinking that
assistant it's getting that thought
process of what's the problem I'm trying
to solve here because it's a customer or
something like that and that's really
where the our best developers come from
it's it's best sorry I promise I want us
to be up speaking that language so if I
can get up there and start putting it
you know some type of composition or
diagram that speaks to business terms
and how I kind of reach it oh yeah
there's a flight there's a date there's
a location well I don't have to say it's
flight you know whatever I want to name
the method is or the class person don't
think like that
it's getting yourself out in into that
thing that was one of the challenges I
would say that I had was with an
engineer not at this particular company
better another one was pull on him that
I that he was really heavy into spring
and really thought in every way of end I
said don't reference to that when we're
only at the business said just strip it
down what does this class mean pretty
soon he started kind of meaning this
relationship he's trying to kind of
thinking a different name for the class
as he was talking been to the that's how
he's kind of translating it into a
business term and pretty soon he started
to see the code in a different
perspectives but after you get done with
all the businesses she goes she goes
like I had to be put classes in this why
they do it this way say and you start to
see how to decouple this was from the
original thinking so you don't want to
be reversing from I need code to get to
my business program now I want my
business problem to work its way to R&D
car
position down into something packaged in
a classes functions or whatever offs
I try to reverse it I came on board
kapow everybody talked about in terms of
servers Gemini Apollo they name - it was
this minute art and I still have people
reference it oh that's that's that's
Minotaur
what about Minotaur what is it that's a
server that's where the code lies I
don't know anything about that
oh I fell due respect it's something in
this person's right because they know
what's out there Minotaur
that's some instance on an ec2 I don't
know a thing about it
well menator is the front end piece
that's kind of expense you're good and
then they've got one called Jemma these
are these are cute names everything but
it's doing nothing for me from a visual
standpoint okay why not just call it
vendor portal I don't first caller I am
portal meaningful names but it's cool
when you're this hipster there's just a
few of us do it let's call it you know
SpongeBob SquarePants
I don't care you know it's it's a goofy
thing yeah and that's just part of
maturity this is part of maturity
getting it there getting those people to
think in terms of I don't think about
from the server perspective don't think
that from the core perspective it's a
function and it really helps the
business I must say when we get service
tickets and that helps them big way cuz
somebody's thinking like that right
there
no cuz it's real tempting to think that
we're at the code is this happening
no I don't think that where's that
person trying to do cuz you might end up
finding it there's none do if the code
is hurry live did that function just
don't exist
yeah and it helps into communication
with the business too big can write both
both directions
uzuki are you actually using the same
nouns writing exactly is here or not if
you're not talking controller controller
controller and it's nothing to them to
the business at all of you're saying of
the user or
jan-ken can the poor whatever is no
can't can't can't
oh that's it can't can't can't oh honey
that's inside that was hilarious kick in
Kansas it's just getting out of it but
that's it that's okay that's just part
of the tour nation curve that's what
differentiates how you might have
learned something to think in terms of
song a this is that's what we look for
so you mentioned that you know you use
the correction and the c4 so when in the
two weeks sprint would you put those
together very good well you guys
entrants appear in the bloody meeting or
first couple days or and who's involved
in creating notes yeah making the call
when I happen to get your scrum master
that's a scratch so scrum masters gonna
be all kinds it so I've had to work with
them and we scaled our team down to 50
people and the scrum master will is
rotate it's not a dedicated person and
so people that have also become a scrum
master my not necessarily not design
anything so I'll go up and ask them is
engineering you know the director you're
saying do we need design on this oh ask
it right up front do we need design on
this know kind of the cases I don't know
do we understand what we've got to do
here and then somebody starts thinking
about from a system or something so I
think back from that like well I'm not
sure and I say okay I explained to me
what we're gonna do there we have to
start thinking and if it's if it's a
deer in the headlights or that it's
there's nothing at that point because
you can't go up and articulate it right
doing I may have my most experienced you
know Jerry shaken it's like that's
probably how we yeah I know exactly how
that's kind of good good for you about
the rest of us perfect that person is
gonna be yeah and it's great because
that person loves the growing to because
of the judgment call if I don't have my
hand well then if I don't watch that
they will go right ahead without design
and we can do the color everything so it
is it had to be an intentional thing
it's not a high as 100 brand wants us to
decide I've got seats yeah they they
wanna they get banished and that debt is
an investment they've seen the merits I
got two of those guys come as I said we
are now doing was he said 12 more points
and each spec that we did before because
we got it we can go farther with it I
know the depth of what's going on here
so we're more efficient you can listen
so there's other stuff coming on us
right
I got a junior developer she's always
asking I do we gonna do a design like I
know what she's I know why they're
asking well yeah they don't understand
it's big but they want that visual that
helps them so there's other people
driving as you get farther on it
presumably just which is part of our our
cadence and there but gangster that take
some things and you have to have some
people that genuinely wanted to come
work it I haven't won engineer as he got
to be familiar with this
he kinda said that you know this this
really isn't for me
I can't expand my carpets I like doing
that that piece of it that's fine too
it's cool that's actually cool
a problem
we're small team so it's like seven
people yeah just really agree bring on
even qi2 because weathered when they got
they got our test scripts I'll just say
hey what's this thing supposed to do hey
Johnny I thought we had we should wrap
it be right back okay alright we're good
so thank you I appreciate it offensive
for at me my great questions